good morning everybody
welcome to morgan district council and
this licensing subcommittee on monday
the 9th
august 2021 we sit today under the
licensing act 2003 to hear an
application made under the act
my name is councillor mark durham and
i've been appointed chairman for this
meeting
uh before we commence the business of
the meeting there are some housekeeping
issues
to run through as usual first of all
please make sure your microphone remains
muted and actually your camera
is irrelevant because we are meeting
face to face for the first time in 18
months so
we haven't got the uh i think your muted
issues um
so uh members we are streaming this
meeting live
uh and being present at this meeting
you're giving your consent to be
recorded um and we don't need to worry
about the hands up feature
on zoom or teams so just please indicate
um appropriately when you wish to speak
and if you uh
wish to remove your mask while speaking
please do
uh item three are apologies for absence
and i understand
that um
we have no apologies item 4
disclosure of interest so we have to
disclose the existence and nature
of any disclosable pecuniary interests
other pecuniary interests or
non-pecuniary interests related to items
of business
on this agenda having regard to
paragraph six to eight inclusive of the
code of conduct for members and members
uh you are also reminded to disclose
such
interest if it you become aware should
the need
arise during the meeting i will kick off
um i have a non-pecuniary interest i am
a personal license holder and have been
a justices on license holder for about
30 years
um and just out of
interest and for the purpose of openness
and transparency i did a company check
on the applicant and uh
it appears that this we share the same
surname
so uh and i'd like to assure everybody
that um
that was a surprise to me as i'm sure it
was a surprise to the applicant when you
just heard who i was this morning and we
are not related
in any way shape or form so any other
disclosures of interest
we have none so we move on to item five
this is the application for a new
premises license at riverside park
station road burnham on crouch this is
found
on pages five to thirty six of your
agenda
and i refer everybody to the aid member
on page two
of the agenda which details the
procedures we're going to follow
this morning can i ask everybody
to check with everybody that you've read
the officer's report and appendices and
the evidence submitted which has been
circulated prior to the meeting
if anybody has any late documentation in
support of the referee
the application this can only be
introduced with the consent of all
parties
okay members have you you have read and
digested yes
thank you very much i think that's quite
clear members a reminder if you wish to
speak on this item please make it known
by
attracting my attention
um okay uh i now call on miss latimer to
provide a brief outline of this
application please
thank you chair the purpose of this
report is to consider
an application for a new premises
license have in regards to
representations received and the
requirement to promote the full
licensing objectives
recommendation that the licensing
subcommittee determines the application
for a new premises license
at riverside park burnham on crouch
taking into consideration
the options that are available as
detailed in section 4.1 below
members are requested to consider an
application by bars for events limited
made under under section 17 of the
licensing act 2003
for a new premises license in respect of
riverside park
having regard to the representations
received and the requirements to promote
the four licensing objectives
the prevention of crime and disorder
public safety the prevention of public
nuisance
the protection of children from harm the
application for a premises license was
received on the 18th of june 2021 and
correctly advertised
by the placing of blue notices at the
premises and publication in a local
newspaper
the public notice was correctly
displayed on the premises for a period
of 28 days
commencing the date after submission of
the application
the premises license application from
bars for events limited applies for the
below activities
the completed application form together
with a plan of the proposed premises
as attached as appendix aid to this
report
in processing this application the
licensing department in accordance with
the act
sent a copy of the full applications
each of the responsible authorities as
listed below
responses to the consultation have been
received from essex police who agreed
conditions with the applicant
a copy of the agreed conditions is
attached as appendix b
no other comments were received from any
other responsible authorities
five representations have been received
from members of the public the
representations are attached as appendix
c
to this report members are advised that
they have the following options when
determining this application
grant the application on the terms and
conditions applied for grant the
application on the terms and conditions
applied for
modified to such extent as considered
appropriate to promote the licensing
objectives
refuse the application in whole or in
part the committee is reminded that the
applicant or any person making
representation in relation to this
matter
may appeal the decision of the council
to the magistrates court
that concludes my report thank you chair
thank you very much uh ms latimer
okay um i now uh invite the applicant uh
mr dharam that sounds strange to make an
opening
statement mr mr durham if you'd like to
go ahead
and present to the panel thank you mr
tom
also sounds strange um
yeah my name's chris i'm the applicant
um i
put the application in following being
approached by morgan council
to come up with something to put into
riverside
park following over a number of years
then receiving requests from
burnham residents for something to
add to the park and beauty and
attraction
to which we came up with the idea of
riverside cafe bar
which as the committee sure is aware
has now been operating under temple
events notices um
three days a week for the last six weeks
with no issues i've been made aware of
at all what it's become apparent is that
it
is doing exactly what it's set out to do
would be a coffee
and food led establishment not an
alcohol establishment
and that it is one that
can doesn't need to go late into the
evening
as a committee may be aware we've agreed
with the police and the licensing
to reduce the closing times
um from the weekend from 10 o'clock
to 9 30. and indeed on the tempe events
notices we only went till 9 30 anyway
but only on two occasions do we even
open until nine o'clock because it just
wasn't warranted um
so we're more than happy to just reduce
that to 9 30
and having read through the
representations from the public
it's obviously apparent that they are
concerned about late night drink in the
park and that sort of thing
as we are we don't want to promote that
which is again
why we're happy to reduce that to 9 30
so that
people are long gone um and indeed as
the knights draw in we have no intention
of opening after dark
as again within the representations we
mentioned about
lack of lighting and that sort of thing
um we haven't put any lighting in
we don't want to be open after dark we
literally the idea is
it's an afternoon and early evening
experience
to experience the beauty of the park and
the river crouch
for people just to sit quietly or have a
coffee and a bacon sandwich
maybe a glass of wine and a cheese
platter and then move on
and carry on with the rest of their day
or evening as they see fit
that concludes my opening statement
thank you
thank you very much mr durham um
are you going to call any witnesses in
support of your application
no no thank you very much indeed um
mr do we have any responsible authority
representation
okay thank you very much indeed so um
members um a few of the questions that i
was going to ask that i'd written down
have actually been
answered so it's your opportunity to
question
the applicant now one thing i'd like to
comment or question and because i
haven't been down there
the plan consists of a aerial photograph
with a white square in it which
not really the most informative i have
to say
could you just describe to the panel
what the building is or or
the nature of the premises please
basically within that area which is a 30
meter by 30 meter area
we sight a the cafe bar which is a
trailer
that opens out it is a black in color so
that it's not
obtrusive it's not sort of garish with
bright colors and that sort of thing
it then in front of that is some park
benches
some of which have been supplied by the
kindly by the council
some by ourselves all wooden benches
again to be
keep with the ambience of the park um
all within that area
we um and then obviously we close it up
and we
generally remove the unit on the days
that we aren't open
oh okay so that was again answering one
of my questions so it's not left on site
it's not left on site it is at the
moment because we have some access
issues that
ourselves and the council are addressing
because
we were going to be coming in across the
car park adjacent to the yacht club
but the yacht club and the council
don't seem to agree that that is allowed
the council meant to be opening up
an existing um access route
to be easier to get on and off because
at the moment
the unit is coming up the um steep bank
which isn't ideal and with the weather
the way it is it's um
for safety reasons i've sort of locked
it up tight and
and left it there but as soon as that
access is done it'll get removed
okay so just going back to my point so
it's a movable trailer that's located
somewhere we're in that
sort of square depending on where you
happen to park it that way it is yes but
basically
always backs on to the hedge to the
existing picnic area
that has been there for a number of
years mainly because the wind is then on
to the back of us
so it requires shelter rather than
everything blowing around in the unit
and just another question so you've been
selling alcohol
under a temporary event notice for about
six weeks
that is correct okay uh
members capture
thank you can i ask you just a couple of
questions your actual
timings you've got on here is 8 30.
um are you actually looking at selling
alcohol from 8 30 in the morning
or are you going to sell that later if
you look the
alcohol sales start at 11 o'clock lovely
friendships at 8 30 so we can do
coffee and bacon sandwiches and that
sort of thing that's fine and the area
have you actually got it
roped off or marked out to say this is
the area that you will be
trading in or is that the whole of the
park that
you've got for trading we haven't roped
it off but because of the 18 benches
we've got there it's
very specific within that but what i
have done is where the notice was
is then um sort of i know where the line
is so we don't encroach
onto other parts of the park but i'm
happy to put something up if
the committee sees fit for that
thank you chairman as you said you
didn't plan to serve alcohol after dusk
after dark would you be open to amending
the condition to
include daylight house only i don't know
how we do that technically i'm just
asking if you would consider that
i'm more than happy because i've got no
intention of being like but after that
thank you and thank you chairman
thank you uh so one of the things you
said was about
enjoying the area
so yeah in terms of after dark
what's what's your definition of after
dark because after dark might mean
one thing to one person something
completely different to somebody else
um basically is as
we all know once the sun goes down it's
there's still light for probably about
half an hour
as soon as the sun goes down within 15
minutes half an hour we would close
so over the last six weeks which you've
had the temporary license
what sort of hours have you been closing
um we
have only actually gone to nine o'clock
twice okay
um and obviously at the moment it's i
think dusk is about half nine quarters
and it's slowly drawing in um
but we ended it twice because it hasn't
been wanted
but also as the nights draw in obviously
the timings will get
less and less um i'd also like to point
out that at the moment
we can only operate when we've got a
contract in place with the council which
that contract ends
on sunday the third of october i believe
so obviously it's a nice draw in
you know we'll see if it becomes four
o'clock during the winter
at that point we probably we won't be
open at all um well that's not the
intention of
being open at this stage but that's
consultation
to see how this has gone and how the
council and ourselves see it moving
forward
i i'm not aware of the contract at all
that the operator has with the council
how long has that been operation
from the beginning so but when when when
did we
when did you start operating the first
weekend in july okay so this year
yes okay um in terms of
this license in terms of this thing why
have you now identified that you want to
sell alcohol when you didn't before
no we were always intending on selling
selling alcohol
it was always going to be coffee lead
right but the idea was
for people to be able to sit and enjoy
a local pint of ale um or a local wine
while sort of taking in the ambience and
and
the menu sort of includes sort of cheese
platters and that sort of thing
so it's much an experience rather than a
case of
let's have a knees up or anything else
which is what i've also
said categorically no music you know
it's about sitting there
and enjoying the surroundings okay
um and in terms of
sort of volumes at the moment what what
sort of volumes have you been selling
so it's eight it's been 80 coffee soft
drinks and food
right 20 alcohol um and
so we've probably only had a handful of
people have more than
one alcoholic drink because it is
literally working exactly as i
anticipated which people come in
they have a bite to eat or they just sit
and have a pint
have a natter and move on it's not about
sitting there all day and that sort of
thing and
at the end of the day in the [ __ ] when
hopefully the weather gets better
and hopefully we do get the license the
idea is i want
throughput of customers so that more
people can experience it
not just have the tables taken up by
just a few people
sitting there all day because that
doesn't work it's not that's not what
it's about
drinking beer has a different effect on
someone's body
than having a cup of tea or coffee so it
it in terms of uh the
need for toilet facilities and and
things like that do you see any issues i
think
because i think at the moment you're
using the council toilets is that
correct
we are using council toilets we have a
key for the toilets so that if
because the council tends to shut them
about six seven o'clock
um their cleaner contract means the
cleaners have to lock them
we then go down and open them up again
and lock them on our way out
and we tell all our customers those are
the toilets there and they're more than
happy to walk down there
but in general what we found is that
mostly because they're only stopping
for one drink there has been no need and
they have just
moved on or been walking that way anyway
okay
thank you um
mr durham i was just looking for details
of the dps
i'm assuming that's yourself is it it is
yes
that was within the application okay
and are you there the whole time i'm
assuming not
at the moment yes i have been um
but the intention isn't that i will be
there all the time but it is to have a
personal license holder
there but all my staff have also been
trained we have our own
um training schedule and questionnaire
um
which all the staff that were working
this weekend
um have passed
and i think i recall that your company
has been trading since 2005 was that
was that right yeah so yeah you're
obviously well aware of i'm not sure
the word trading in the last 18 months
is correct but
that's that's that's fine but uh no i
think that's
that's important to know um
could you just just for the benefit of
the panel just give us a little bit of
an idea of the sorts of things that you
are
selling in terms of food um yes we
are doing sort of bacon and sausage
sandwiches using bacon and sausages
from the secret butcher in the district
we then do a selection of other
sandwiches cakes
scones plowmans cheese platters and
afternoon tea
okay
just a couple of questions are you
buying all of your stuff is that all
being sourced locally we are doing our
best to source it locally all our bread
is coming from um burnham bakery
all our veg is coming i can't remember
the name of it but just
up from the bakery going towards um
up the road north there is a roadside
um greenway so they do a lot of their
their own growing
so we're using all the sort of fresh veg
and that sort of thing from there
um the meat is all and our mature and
extra mature cheddar is coming from the
secret butcher
our beer mainly from craft foundry at
the moment
it doesn't have using more
because it would not selling that much
alcohol
wines are generally for newhall
vineyards or vineyards
we have contacted almost all the
vineyards in the district
but new hall is the only one that
actually got back to us
all of us didn't email us back at all um
so you said wherever possible um or
we've got
uh the gin from manchester united
they're well sound fine
and the other thing i was going to ask
is you say that of an evening you have
the key for the toilets and that you
open it and lock it up
does that also go for arrangement of
cleaning them so if
somebody does go in there and make a
mess who is checking those toilets and
i check it before we've closed up and so
far there hasn't been
anything having spoken to for our
customers i'm not i think only about two
of our customers actually needed to
go down there later in the evening thank
you
yes of course thank you chairman
uh in terms of your uh experience so far
the last few weeks
what are your peak times and when are
you busiest so we're busiest
um between 9 30 and 11
for tea coffee and baking soda
sandwiches
and then generally between one
and about half three four um
which again is mainly coffee and cake um
a few sort of glasses of wine and the
odd pint
and we've had one weekend with actually
really decent weather
and we did have a sort of third peak
time which was about half past six seven
o'clock
um literally people walking their dogs
and have sat down
had a coffee or glass of wine um i think
one gentleman did have a pint
um stay for a cheese platter or shared
cheese letter
and then moved on and on those occasions
by
eight o'clock i think we only had six
people left
okay so and
in terms of attracting customers what
what have you done to do that
um all we've done is um some advertising
on social media
and an a board on the key sort of
pointing
to us um but locate we want it to build
by word of mouth and not sort of the
advertising campaign and that sort of
thing
because we do want to attract the right
sort of clientele
that are going to sit and enjoy the park
and we've priced ourselves for that as
well so we're
more expensive on the coffee and on the
food
and on the alcohol as far as i'm aware
definitely than the pubs
and the other cafes in in the town on
purpose
okay thank you could i ask the officers
of course you can
guess counsellors uh so in in terms of
the
the the hours and in terms of this
adjustment about in terms of
you know closing around dusk just after
dog
what's your view on that
can i just say um first of all i'm sure
my colleagues will have something to say
on that trouble with
although i've seen conditions about
closing at dusk dusk is very
unclear exactly and i think councillor
siddal you mentioned
um it means one thing to one and
something else or something
and i don't wouldn't advise you to put
in a condition
about closure at dusk it's very
difficult for
mr mcdermott's team to actually enforce
that and to know when that's the case
i think you need to put in a specific
time and that's what obviously the
applicant has done
so if you're satisfied with the times
he's given
and the evidence he's given i i wouldn't
recommend
changing it to dusk yeah
that's my concern well yeah i i could
just take yes i'll come back to you
thompson but um of course there are
published sunrise and sunset times
so i'm assuming you could for example
and i'm only just saying for example
stipulate
one hour after sunset because that is a
prescribed
time that changes throughout the year
is that technically possible it is
technically possible but it complicates
things
you're absolutely right um chairman
there are published times
but then if there is for example an
issue of enforcement
if you've got a clear time set time that
everybody knows all the staff know what
time it is that are working there
there's no issue about having to look on
the internet if you can get access to
what are the closing times
it's just so much clearer chairman if
you have a set
time for purposes of enforcement and not
just enforcement for the staff
themselves
and the public to know as well
i see the officers nodding in councillor
thompson
thank you chairman well i was just
asking on you know whether the
applicant was open to it i did say i
didn't know how this was going to be
done technically and i assumed we'd do
that in another part of the meeting but
um i would have i was just finding out
if
the applicant would have would object if
we came up with such a plan but if such
a plan is
already shot down well so be it thank
you
yes of course may i may make a
suggestion particularly as we're
mainly looking at being open during the
summer
is that we maybe say that it's 21 30
from the beginning of may to the end of
september but if we were to open during
the winter
let's say we then put a different
stipulation for the six months
there of say seven o'clock or 1900
just to make it clearer and try and take
on your point i do take that on board
and also take them aboard a better staff
and that sort of thing um
as i say we don't want to be open after
dark but if we can come up with
something
between us for the wording to be correct
to make it easier for everybody
and i'm more than able to yeah after
this we can take legal advice on what is
you know what is legal and also what is
workable so
we we will do that in accordingly
can i just ask a person mr geller that i
mean so this
this has been trading for six weeks
selling alcohol
um do we know that have there been any
complaints or have there been any
complaints to the licensing officer
regarding
um there's no there's no complaints
about this particular
uh venue uh one thing i would say is
um and it's referenced in one of the
appendices um the council are looking at
bringing in a public space protection
order
for that area um the idea behind the
public space protection order is that
it's basically there to try and tackle
any possible anti-such behavior that
could arise
um so in terms of people drinking
responsibly fine carry on that's
you know we're trying to encourage
people to behave in a positive way
for example we feel that you know people
are
leaving causing nuisance alcohol-related
nuisance there will be conditions to
tackle that we can tap into and use
so we we can or we will apply for a
for a pspa it's currently going through
the stage of being uh
finalized so we've completed the public
consultation that's being
assessed um i can give you early
indications that the uh the public view
was very positive towards it
and so it's just a question of getting
that final report together and then
rolling that out so that will actually
give the authority more teeth to deal
with any issues absolutely so
in terms of the conditions related to
alcohol um
the first instance you can ask someone
to surrender what they've got to drink
and dispose of it
and the second instance you can then
find them if the antisocial behavior
continues so again it's it's about
encouraging good behavior and providing
additional enforcement support
okay i'm sorry um ms lantern did you
have a
has anybody come into your department
with any issues
um i was just going to confirm that
we've haven't received any complaints in
licensing either
any issues thank you and i'm just going
to ask one legal point so we are
considering a premises license mr quelch
before um
okay i'll rephrase that are we
considering a premises license
for anything in that
white square
or are we granting a premises license
for the mobile
unit and i'm just mindful of the fact
this is our assumption yes yes so that
white block would be the licenseable
area as it were so that is what you're
granting
a license for or not for um
and you can obviously do a partial grant
as well
but that's what the application is for
so any premises licensure
but it would also be a premises license
applied to the area
not necessarily this applicant am i
correct
well it's it's for the premises
licensed only as you know chairman
better than i probably
um uh from your own experience if it's a
premises license
to a holder of that license that
premises license connects into the
application
that application has from what i
understand from this latimer
that white area is the extent to which
the licensable activities can apply they
cannot apply outside
of it now if someone walks away with
alcohol of course they can do that
um as you can walk outside and you can
walk away from them
so it's just the selling area
it's just the yeah it's just the actual
selling about what in that area
if people walk outside that's up to them
that i that i accept but we you know a
premises
license is exactly that it refers to a
premises
and operators obviously then have to
have a personal license which moves with
the personal license holder
but the premises license is applicable
to
the building or the area and should that
change
hands there is a transfer procedure to
change that but we
you know as the applicant has already
said he only has a contract with this
authority until
the end of september if this authority
doesn't
grant him one for next year what is the
situation
regarding you know there is a there will
be an
premises license for that three that
white blob as you said chairman uh
um
so if there's some contractual
difficulties between
mr daryl and modern district cancer
for some reason or other they want to
park company
this
to take place so if we didn't give trans
consent
then if the district council wanted to
continue
and i think this is outside in terms of
this actual
application but just to give you a wider
picture
if
right okay my concern and you're quite
right
count mister is you know mr durham's is
has got a long established company
clearly operating as a
as a in the correct way
but there are other operators out there
that may not be quite as
um vigilant as this particular applicant
and
you know my concern is that we're
opening the floodgates in
subsequent years to somebody who may not
be
quite as conscientious
and you know the license transfer for
whatever may go to somebody else
you know put it this way it used to be
an awful lot easier back in my day when
you stood in front of a magistrate and
got a justice is on licence
but um but as you say chairman
and i know as you know this from your
own experience and knowledge
um you can't take that into into account
no i'm aware
that that is not irrelevant you you
can't imagine what might be happening
in the same way if i might just give
advice to the committee
in public so people here and maybe the
um
people making the interested parties are
making a listening to this
in their appendix c um
representations they haven't given any
evidence
that you that you can consider to be
evidence
of any public order
issues all they've done is put forward
fears
and and those aren't really evidence and
under the guidance the 182
um guidance from the government that
that says when you determine
applications of chapter 9.43 of the 182
guidance the authorities determined you
should be evidence
based and unfortunately the members of
the public have not pulled forward in
mind you as a legal advisor
which is for you to decide that but i
don't see anything
of an evidence-based representation
hence the questions whether anything's
been reported to us so
and you know clearly i think the police
would have made representation had they
received any issues so
then one to guess councillor skills can
i ask a question mr geller please
of course mr can you clarify for me that
if we bring in
a public order um
thing on this thing that that covers the
rest of that
area in that part and therefore could be
enforceable by your officers
if somebody was to walk off with a drink
and cause nuisance
yes it does um so the way public space
protection orders typically work
um you know within town centre areas
where there's pubs or you know
parks where there's retail facilities it
covers the whole area
so in effect it also covers the area
where
the licensable activity takes place um
obviously the license of activity is
still allowed to take place the active
anti-such behavior only occurs
you know when it's it's been deemed that
something has happened that it shouldn't
be
so for example if someone is being rowdy
while they're drinking it might be
happening within that squared area
they're still
um eligible for enforcement activity
bias so absolutely we can continue to
enforce both within the white area and
the wider area
so the curse for the pspo is is the
whole of riverside past the whole
riverside okay
were you aware of that mr stern i wasn't
when i put the application in but
through
and the representations i was and i
think it's brilliant
you think it's it works clearly is a
significant
factor yes yep
so another question for the officers uh
are there any concerns
uh regarding environmental health or
anything like that at all has anything
come forward in terms of
from the council uh so far that there's
nothing that we've been made aware of
okay thank you and a question from mr
um at the moment uh
in what containers is your alcohol sold
in
if people are sitting at the tables uh
we're using
reusable plastic cups um so
they don't just go to landfill and that
sort of thing um if people
want to walk away with alcohol then as
the police although with the tempe
events notice we don't
have to do this we have been abiding by
what the police have asked
which is that it'd be in a lidded
container
so but so far i think we've had
two people want to to wander off with a
pims
and one person had sat with
somebody and had a cheese platter and
they wanted to go home
and continue with the same wine and said
could we buy a bottle to take away
which we we obviously did so that was
completely sealed
okay in terms of the hours
and so i'm going to see it from your
point of view in terms of these habits
and uh perhaps in september we have a
fantastic
indian summer and yeah it gets dark
quite early in september and it's but
it's a really hot evening
and we we then say okay but your your
hours are whatever
time that we agreed to um
and you want to open them so you so
immediately in terms of that situation
you as a as a parameters holder are in a
difficult situation
because you want to stay open but we've
changed your hours to
to an earlier time um so i have great
concerns about us
fiddling about with these hours um in
terms of an officer's point of view
and then enforcing it and also in terms
of the practical point of view from you
um so i i i have concern
concerns about those things and and
being too vague
about it um from both us
as as operators and also in terms of of
your opportunities
um yeah in terms of that and hopefully
you can see that point
yeah because we might have a very good
september hopefully
have you any comment mr um for you um
the the simple thing is this is that if
there is
other than our lighting in within the
unit there is no lighting there
there's no easy way to put lighting in
there so
um in that area so this is why we intend
on chatting before that doesn't matter
how busy it gets
thank you for your comments at the end
of the day yes it'll be lovely to have
the situation
that all 18 or 20 tables are taken and
it's getting dark it's like well
wouldn't it be nice if we could stay
open
but it's not practical because of no
light
you know we won't be able to see to get
to the tables and that sort of thing
we want to get by my staff and myself
off site safely and and that needs to be
um as it's getting dark not once it's
dark
um so the other thing just um i don't
know what i was going to say now
um coming into the the the issues of
possibly if the relationship with
council
broke down um with myself is that i
don't know the
legalities of this but obviously we
can't operate at the moment unless the
council say
you can operate on our land is if it was
legal to do so
maybe there was a condition on the
license that that license is only
valid if alongside it there is a
contract
that we're with the council that we're
able to trade which then means if it did
break down
actually the license wouldn't be valid i
don't know what the legalities are with
that
did you understand what i was trying to
say though
that's a legal point we can we can
discuss afterwards
um i think you know looking at the hours
and i know that that's a sort of
thorny issue i mean for the last
goodness knows how long i've run events
on august bank holiday weekend and by 9
30 it's pretty much the last knockings
isn't it so
into september it's pitch dark at half
nine so
um okay members have you any
final questions for the officers
um you're entitled to make a closing
statement sir
um other than to thank you for your time
and
and and hope that you see
this favorably um i think we've we've
covered everything
um and addressed the concerns
as far as i'm aware so thank you very
much yeah thank you very much i think
members all said what they wanted to
um so in accordance with
point 10 uh this meeting will now close
uh
and what we do now mr daram is we
discuss um
between ourselves to make our decision
we can take legal advice if we
need to clarify a legal point uh you
will find out within five days
of our decision so members thank you
very much for
uh your time we will have a little uh
discussion
uh shortly so we're going to close this
meeting formal meeting at 11 15
and um we will we will meet
shortly where we sat actually if that's
so we'll stay in this
in this room mr and thank you very much
for your time
it's good to find out there's another
another durham in the events business
even though we're not related
you